how can we de-escalate heated
negotiation tone of voice is critical
late night FM DJ voice calming soothing
voice whatever advantage that gives you
take it many times each individual
tactic might just be a small Advantage
but the cumulative effect is what you're
looking for you're looking to score up
some point so the calming soothing
voices start with that's at best not
going to aggravate the situation well
commanding voice is an aggravating voice
repeat back to them what they're saying
a lot of times people just want to have
their say if all I have to do to get you
to go away is to let you feel like
you've had your say then if I repeat it
back it's clear your point has gotten
through the most effective way to
deactivate negativity is to Simply call
it out sometimes you got to call it out
more than once but there's brain science
that backs us up it's the most effective
stuff you're going to solve enough of
your problems just with those two things
that if there's anything that requires
any sort of an escalation at least you
didn't need to escalate unnecessarily I
like that a lot are you very very
correct as well about people just
needing to be heard